you may think you know the words that
sit plainly in black on your page but
don't be fooled
some words are capable of taking on
different guises masquerading as nouns
verbs and adjectives that alter their
meanings entirely this seeming
superpower is called lexical ambiguity
it can turn words and sentences into
mazes that mess with our minds for
example consider the following buffalo
buffalo buffalo buffalo buffalo buffalo
buffalo buffalo that may sound like
nonsense but it's actually a
grammatically correct sentence how well
buffalo is a proper noun a noun and a
verb it refers to an animal also known
as a bison an American city and it can
also mean to bully these different
interpretations create a sequence of
words that is grammatically correct as
it stands though it helps to add in a
few implied phrases and punctuation
marks to reveal what's really going on
Buffalo Buffalo are bison from the city
of Buffalo and this sentence has three
groups of them group a which is bullied
by Group B bully's Group C in other
words bison from Buffalo that other
bison from Buffalo bully also bully
bison from Buffalo if you let each
Buffalo perform its role the meaning
becomes apparent what if the bunch of
bullying Buffalo decides to cross the
ocean not just on any ship but a ship
shipping ship shipping shipping ships
that sentence sounds just as outrageous
but there's logic to the babble ship can
mean a vessel and to transport when we
sub in those meanings
clearer picture emerges here we have a
huge ship carrying vessel transporting
ships that themselves are designed to
carry goods across the sea a ship
shipping ship shipping shipping ships
how about some entertainment on board
this unusual vessel to offset the
scuffling Buffalo consider the Kin Kin
Kin Kin Kin Kin Kin Kin Kin Kin Kin Kin
hear the word can comes in many guises
there's can-can the flamboyant pants can
that means able to and can figuratively
meaning to outperform by sticking in a
comma and including the implied meanings
the sentence becomes clearer can-can
dances that can-can dances are able to
outperform can also outperform other
tin-can dances you wouldn't necessarily
use any of these sentences in a
conversation they're just too ridiculous
yet they serve as an extreme example of
just how tangled everyday language can
be lexical ambiguities
sail into our speech and writing all the
time spreading confusion and
misunderstanding wherever they can can